okay hello everyone welcome to another q
a about history of Science and
Technology I see a number of questions
here
uh
okay I'm not sure if this one really
counts but it's from Lala here
do you think it will be possible to
recreate historical figures as Bots to
interact with and get their perspectives
on current research areas
interesting question
I mean okay so the issue is
that
as time moves on we have new Concepts
and if you create a bot let's say an
Alan Turing bot
um or an Aristotle bot
and you're going to create it by
training it from the Corpus of material
that those people left behind and
for example the uh the touring bot
simply won't have a
uh uh something about large language
models let's say or something about
um
oh I don't know what's actually new in
the world something about I don't know
object-oriented programming or something
I'm not sure that's the best example of
a new thing but um
so that bot will be sort of disconnected
from those areas of knowledge because
you know you train the bot from the kind
of um the language that existed at that
time now I suppose a question would be
is there a bridge that can be made let's
say to uh what's a good New Concept
um
uh well a live stream let's say the
concept of live streaming is there
something which sort of exists in kind
of meaning space which connects the
concept of live streaming to something
which Alan Turing would have known about
or more extremely that Aristotle would
have known about
um that's an interesting question and I
suppose it's conceivable because you
know one of the things that tends to
happen is this kind of uh this apparent
chaining of concepts by virtue of the
fact that this thing that has a perhaps
a thing which has a new name is somehow
seen to be you know that there will be
documents that say live streaming is the
process of doing blah blah blah which
then effectively connects that name to
something that moves it close in meaning
space to the thing that it is described
as being like
so okay my first response was they're
just going to be a lot of words that
those Bots just don't know
um but my second response I think is
that there might be some sort of bridges
between things that were known and
things that um we have today I suppose a
good exercise will be to imagine I've
thought about this before actually you
know you you were talking to the
reconstituted Aristotle bot or the
Pythagoras bot or the Newton bot or
whatever and you're sitting there with
your laptop and assume it's a nice
multimodal bot so it's able to see you
in your laptop and all those kinds of
things
um and then the question is
how can you explain in its terms what
the laptop is
let's say to well any of those figures
um
you know I think to touring at the end
of his life 1954 he had used an actual
electronic computer so the fact that
there is a miniaturized version of that
would be unsurprising so now I'm touring
of 1936 when he was first inventing
Turing machines a little bit more
surprising kind of like
um it's a I think for him it will be
kind of a wow that it goes from this
concept of a universal machine to the
actuality of a laptop that can run all
these different programs I think um that
would be quite a quite a surprise but
perhaps not an incomprehensible surprise
I think
that um when you go further back in time
to a Newton or to a Pythagoras or to an
Aristotle I think it becomes quite
challenging to explain what a laptop is
um and uh you know I've I've thought
somehow that um the pythagoreans for
example one might be asking kind of you
know it might be like a a box of souls
so to speak it has this kind of
intrinsic animation that intrinsic
ability to do things that is sort of
reminiscent in that time more of things
that were thought of as having Souls
like like people or maybe some animals
and things like this
and um then you could you could ask sort
of who are the souls what are the souls
whose souls are in this laptop and then
it becomes a complicated thing it's like
all the people who've written content
and created programs and so on that are
now running on the laptop in what sense
are their souls somehow embedded in the
laptop gets it gets very weird and I
think but I think that those are the
types of explanatory forms that one
would have to use I mean I it is of
course a thing to be thought about in
our times of
when you are looking from the future uh
looking at the from now to the Future
those things which will become
well-known Concepts in the future how do
we explain them today and in a sense
somebody like me that's a large part of
kind of what I have spent my my time
doing is figuring out things which are
sort of artifacts from the future and
you try to explain them today and
sometimes it's really challenging
um and sometimes it's it's kind of uh my
efforts of exposition are sort of partly
born out of a desire to to be able to
explain artifacts in the future today
and one of the things that tends to
happen is you invent names for things
and those become sort of they eventually
that name eventually builds up kind of a
a certain not I wouldn't say mythology
but it builds up a certain a certain
structure around it you know the concept
of computational irreducibility which I
introduced in 1984 I think has now built
up sort of a big enough snowball of
Concepts around it that it begins to be
something which is well situated for
many purposes but when it was sort of
raw at the beginning it was certainly
explainable but I think it had it
becomes easier and easier to explain the
more kind of network there is around the
concept
and so you know it is an interesting
thing to what extent there are things
that we can imagine from the future and
can we conceptualize them today and
that's kind of asking the same type of
thing as taking the culture today and
moving it back and trying to explain it
to Aristotle or something
um and I think uh you know it's
interesting to see that that there are
things which I will be explainable
because they are features of The Human
Condition effectively there are things
deeply you know tied into The Human
Condition which really hasn't in some
intrinsic sense changed much over the a
few thousand years
um and uh you know this question of how
do you explain things you know in in the
future perhaps there'll be some you know
virtualized analog of of uh Human
Condition and there'll be all kinds of
uh you know connections between biology
and digital kinds of things that are
very different from what we have today
and it may be extremely difficult to
explain kind of um sort of uh
experiences and so on from that time
it's kind of like uh one asks the
question what it's what is it like to be
a fill in the X you know a kind of
animal a you know a bat a cat uh
whatever else a computer for that matter
what's it like to be such and such and
we have people have a hard time
explaining that or internalizing that
but if you imagine sort of the the uh uh
the the person from the future or the
analog of a person in the future what's
it like to be a that thought about from
our situation today it can be a very
challenging thing
well let's see
um
Emmanuel
probably not the real name here is
asking why do many great mathematicians
complete their most influential work in
their early twenties
you know I think that's partly a myth
I think that
what tends to happen is this
at some level people have a certain a
given person has a certain way of
thinking about things
and I you know I could say that in my
own case it has to do with sort of
finding primitive elements of of uh of
some complicated collection of ideas and
then building back up sort of an
engineering structure based on those
it's kind of very much a break things
down into these kind of uh symbolic
components so to speak from which things
can be constructed That's my kind of uh
uh mode of operation or something and
things it turns out there's a wide range
of things to which one can do that
whether it's a fundamental Theory of
physics whether it's constructing
computational language whether it's
other kinds of things that turns out to
be a very fertile kind of Mo so to speak
and I think that
it's often the case that any given
person has a certain way of thinking
about things
and that way of thinking about things
will often manifest quite early in their
life sometimes it requires some
development because the it it it it kind
of it gradually kind of deepens and and
what is gradually able to enunciate
better what that way of thinking is and
and connect it to things and so on but
if we take it as that people tend to
have some definite way of thinking about
things that who knows how it's how it's
built in so to speak
let's say it manifests quite early there
may very well be things where that way
of thinking about things just allows one
to pick some low-hanging fruit
and I think that's what has happened in
a number of cases with people where sort
of the great discoveries were made very
early in their lives is they were
fortunate enough that the particular way
of thinking was a good fit with the
ambient kind of uh uh situation in
science let's say and they were able to
pick some low-hang fruit now many
different things can happen it could be
the case that a particular way of
thinking about things isn't relevant
when one's 20 years old but by the time
the world has changed and one's 50 years
old suddenly the world has changed and
that way of thinking now becomes
relevant and there's some potentially
low-hanging fruit to be picked but I
think that I you know I remember having
this conversation with Benoit mandelbrot
the the creator of fractals not somebody
who who um I think he he
um
uh not somebody who well he had all
sorts of uh strange interactions with me
but but any case one of the things that
I remember him saying was kind of um uh
complaining about how everybody thought
that uh sort of great work was always
done by the young and his point was if
you are going to integrate many
different areas you have a much better
chance to do that when you are when you
know more and you know about more
different areas and that's much more
likely to happen when you're older than
when you're younger and his claim was
that kind of the the discoveries of the
young are these Point discoveries where
you can kind of just go in and kind of
make a surgical strike on some area of
Science and make progress but these big
integrative kinds of uh ways of thinking
about things are more the domain of the
older of older folk and I think there's
some some truth to that idea
I think that um in
I mean in in
if you look I I did once look at this
actually I wrote a piece about ramujan
who was somebody who was notable for
having done things when they were
comparatively Young
um a mathematician
um I did look at kind of uh I think I
looked at name theorems in mathematics
and I looked at the age of the person at
the time when that name theorem was
produced and it is quite a broad
distribution
um and uh we we have the data for that
in in um uh in our knowledge base
actually of of name theorems of
mathematics and and the people who made
them and when the theorem was produced
so you can compute their age and so on
um so I think I think it's a bit of a
myth but as I say
for instance even in the case of
ramanujan his kind of uh Mo was was
essentially being a very good calculator
with numbers and algebra and so on and
being able to form hypotheses by doing
essentially mathematical experiments and
he started doing that kind of pretty
young and he got interesting results now
he also died quite young so didn't have
the opportunity to go on and produce
results that are at a much greater age
but um so I I think it's um
um
uh I as I say I I think it's sort of a
myth that um great mathematics is done
by people young I uh one of the people
who who propagated that myth was um uh
JH Hardy mathematician who sort of
flourished in the 1910s to 1930s in
Cambridge and I think Hardy wrote a book
called the mathematician's apology
um that uh uh sort of talks about how I
don't remember all the details but more
or less how it's all downhill after you
know mathematics has done as he would
say at that time by young men young
people I would say more accurately
um but uh the um I think that the um
uh I have to say I think Hardy's reason
for
um writing that had to do much more with
his personal situation than it did with
any kind of careful study of the data I
mean Hardy himself was a bit of a a sort
of a a dower character
um and uh he
um I think had a bit of a sort of a a
crisis about um whether he would do sort
of great mathematics uh I don't think
any of the mathematics he did was
incredibly incredibly mind-bogglingly
great I think he was sort of in a in a
good place at a good time and he was a
good mathematician
um but uh I think when he got to his I
don't know 40s 50s maybe he was like
feeling I'm all washed up and so he
writes this book it says mathematics is
only done by the young and then people
believe that have ever more you know I
think um as I recall the um
uh uh I don't remember the the um I
think the the main edition of
mathematicians apology has a
uh has an introduction written by C.P
snow
I'm remembering correctly but somehow I
remember talking to Freeman Dyson
um uh who was not always my favorite
character but um I remember talking to
Freeman Dyson about um
JH Hardy and um actually I talked to
another person about GH Charlie who had
known him as well and they really
described him as a rather
um well I suppose Tower would be a
um perhaps a good term for it
um but but definitely not
the um
uh the most upbeat of characters so to
speak so I think it's sort of a shame
that that he kind of um uh threw his uh
fairly uh eloquent writing in in um in a
mathematician's apology sort of I think
that propagated the idea of math as done
by the young now of course there are
examples of people who did their their
math young
um partly and we know that because they
died young as well so for example
Everest
um sort of inventor of group Theory uh
from the 1830s
um who uh was also was died at the age
of I think 21 or so having uh sort of
created this this interesting New
Direction in abstract mathematics I
think it was probably a case where it
was that was his sort of Mo and and uh
you know it manifested young I think he
was uh you know he had the perhaps
a feature that he was not only a sort of
a new mathematics kind of person he was
also a new world order kind of person
and quite a political activist
um which in France in the 1820s was a
dangerous thing to be and uh somehow he
got set up to to fight a duel which was
didn't I think a skill in in dueling did
not come with with skill in in abstract
mathematics and he didn't didn't win
um but uh and and then died as a result
of that
so
let's see
it's a question from atore does
prompting as in for llms have historical
precursors
that's an interesting question so one
feature of prompting
you know prompting is you are
uh your sort of telling the llm what you
wanted to do one thing I've noticed
about prompting is it's actually it
really requires careful Exposition you
are trying to explain to the llm what
you wanted to do you're trying to kind
of have the thing you tell it sort of
map into things that it's seen on the
web before that will allow it to sort of
continue from that prompt and I've
noticed in our efforts at prompt
engineering that if you see something
where you as a human say Hey What on
earth does that mean the llm doesn't
really stand a chance so it really is a
place where there is a premium on sort
of very clear Exposition so in in some
sense prompting for an llm is a bit like
giving instructions to humans it's kind
of like you know do uh you know how do
you specify clearly what you want to
have happen whether you're a a teacher
who's trying to write something about
what you want the student The Prompt
that you want to give a student to write
the essay or something like that
for some reason I'm reminded of of uh
this some military disasters where the
prompt wasn't well given like The Charge
of the Light Brigade and the Crimean War
um was well maybe maybe that wasn't a
problem with prompting maybe that was
just a problem with communication but
the the you know uh or or the um uh what
is it maybe um uh what was it in the
Thousand A.D or something the um uh
Thomas Beckett the uh uh who was the oh
my gosh King of France I think who um
famously said to his Knights about the
then Archbishop must be must have been
later than that I'm I'm losing track of
my history but anyway famously said you
know who will rid me of this quarrelsome
no Troublesome priest or some such other
thing and and the nights go off and um
uh assassinate
um the Archbishop
um at least I think that happened
historically it certainly happened in in
a play about that subject and that was
sort of a oops they misunderstood The
Prompt in some sense so I suppose
prompting has as a historical precursor
um
the uh this idea of um uh
um of of humans giving prompts you know
I was thinking in terms of historical
precursors sort of a question of what's
a historical precursor of the whole
Chachi DT phenomenon and I think I think
the answer is it's kind of like the
invention of the telephone
and here's how that goes
so computation is sort of an enabling
technology that gets everywhere and
informs makes makes a lot of new things
possible a little bit like electricity
did in the 1700s early 1800s and so on
and just like we can now say there's a
computational version of every field X
so in the past and the present we say
there's an electrical version of
everything from you know kettles to cars
to whatever else and so sort of
electricity is kind of like the
computation and it kind of spreads
through different things but the the
question really becomes how does that
sort of get humanized and what had
happened in the development of the
telephone was people certainly knew that
that there was the possibility to have
sort of an electrical communication
process
um but people hadn't managed to work
make it work they hadn't managed to get
it to a sort of human level it's just
like people had imagined that it was
possible to make a text generation
system and there were certain
experiments on that to go all the way
back to the 1950s but it never really
Rose to the level of being of human
interest so to speak until basically the
end of last year when Chachi PT came on
the scene
um where it sort of got Above This
threshold of being sort of human level
and I kind of think that's somewhat
analogous to what happened with the
telephone where yes you could have sort
of a communication between you know
thing going down electrical wire but if
you were holding that thing up to your
ear you would never understand
intelligible speech and then the you
know Alexander Graham Bell Elijah Eliza
Aisha Elisha gray the other person right
the um uh
um their invention in what
1875 I think
um that uh I think it was 1875 and I I
sort of remember that date because 1876
there was a centennial Exposition
um in Philadelphia which for example
Kelvin went to and Kelvin gave a report
on I think he called the maybe he called
it the electrical telephone I'm not sure
something like that gave a report on an
early demonstration of the telephone by
Bell
um so
any case I think that's the point at
which kind of the this level of sort of
human accessibility
um was uh became a thing or in that case
communication uh By You Know by
electricity so to speak
um but I thought that was sort of an
interesting analogy that it had been
just like AI
and sort of text generation have been a
thing for many many decades it kind of
only reached the threshold where it
became sort of of human use at a
particular moment
um now I think
talking about
um prompting and uh kind of how do you
how do you sort of Give an example and
then know how to continue
um I I think it's
really uh
it's something I'm trying to think what
other what other cases there are of that
I mean it's kind of give an example now
follow it or something is a thing that I
suppose you see used in I don't know
whether it's used in animal training
used in things like this I'm not sure I
think it's a very human kind of thing
it's a it's a sort of Almost shockingly
Human capability uh and something we're
now seeing in llms
um
the tour is asking would find them have
been that Feynman have been a great
prompt engineer
uh I'm trying I'm trying to think about
that I think he would have uh he would
have tried many different things I I
will say that um
um
I there's a certain
there's a certain let me try this kind
of puzzly he was he was quite into sort
of puzzle type questions and so on
um and I think he would have uh eagerly
tried out a lot of strange slightly
paradoxical uh kinds of questions
um and seen what the llm actually did on
those
whether he would have been able to
develop an intuition as we're all having
trouble doing
um for sort of What kinds of prompts
work and what don't I I don't know
um
let's see
uh
um
okay I think
Jake he was asking how do you think
future researchers will look back at the
current time in history
we look at bones and architecture to
determine facts about the past what will
they look at to determine facts of our
time
um
I think
that this time in history
is one of the first where there's just a
huge amount of material that's being
recorded
I think that
you know even the very term sort of
historical times
is
is kind of you know we think of history
as sort of beginning when things were
written down and when we have some some
sign of what happened I mean that's
that's kind of recorded history is
begins in a sense with with writing and
the recording of of uh of what happened
now there were certain cultures in which
more was recorded than others and there
were for example
we know
quite a lot about the Babylonians
because they recorded all kinds of stuff
and the and the medium on which they
recorded things clay tablets sort of uh
baked in the Sun or whatever else uh
have survived very well through time we
know practically nothing about let's say
the Phoenicians
um who were clearly a highly developed
trading civilization
um but who left behind very little
written material I don't know even on
what medium they they they committed it
to uh and we know that that alphabet has
has partly evolved into our own
alphabets but we don't I think have so
any significant uh volume of writing now
in the case of um
uh uh from let's say Roman times we have
stone inscriptions uh we have that well
also from Babylonian times we have many
more clay tablets and things
um we also have a sort of continuous
copying going down the centuries of some
of the the major works of of Greek and
Roman literature and so on
um I think
that this in a sense that continual
copying is like oh we're going to keep
the data continually live on disks or
something rather than backing it up to
tape and having the risk that the tape
that we made today will not be readable
in 30 years
um so I think that that sort of copy
copy copy technique
um is is what's happening with with the
maintenance of kind of live things in
live storage Live digital storage which
lots of things are at this point
I think that um uh you know what's the
analog of the stone inscriptions what's
the analog of the thing that we write
today and we're always going to be able
to read in the future
um well it was books uh those are kind
of going much more digital
um and I think it is a little bit more
questionable what can be
um red uh in in the future uh from these
digital kinds of things unless they are
maintained as live continuously
um you know I know that for example
people who've done I don't know medical
research uh where they look at medical
records from let's say World War II
and they were all on paper and they're
around they exist the ones from like the
Gulf War were on computers and when the
computers came back from the war many of
them were erased and so the records are
just gone
um so it's a case where sort of the the
more recent digital technology which has
the advantage you can store a lot more
stuff if you were storing all the data
we store digitally on paper you know
probably the whole earth will be covered
that's an interesting calculation
actually if you store the data of um uh
that um that we have uh even on the web
well actually in that that one I can I
can easily say you wouldn't have the
Earth would not be deep in paper based
on printing out the web because the web
is only maybe 10 billion pages of
visible stuff and uh you know there's
eight billion people and they do not
cover the Earth densely so if we went
for so even at 100 times the 10 billion
Pages
um that you might have if you you know
following every page and if you looked
at sort of uh Deep Web kinds of things
um the uh you know I don't think you're
not you're not covering the Earth in a
giant uh coating of paper by by printing
out the web so so it's still still very
possible to do that
um but obviously there's a lot of
automated data that's being taken and uh
automated video that's being taken I
mean I think a larger fraction of the
sort of the the
um General storage in the world computer
storage in the world is taken up with
video at this point
um and that might be um uh might be a
slightly more extensive
but I think uh so then the question is
really
you're storing all this stuff
and there is a certain feature of if
you're going to make a stone inscription
you probably have to really care about
what it says there's a bunch of effort
to make the stone inscription if you're
going to just sort of keep something in
digital form just like you know take
that picture it's incredibly fast to
take the picture it just goes onto your
you know into your cloud storage system
or your hard drive or whatever else
um it's it's very easy you're going to
take tons of those things and and people
do
and so the question of what matters you
know you go back and look at the history
and you say well this particular giant
inscription that somebody really took a
lot of trouble carving that probably is
something people really cared about
let's go and read it if you've got uh
you know a billion photographs or
something you say well which ones of
these does anybody care about but we
have to go try and look through them
potentially to find out which ones we
care about I think that a couple of
things will happen first of all it's
much less obvious what one cares about I
mean it's kind of like the story of the
web of oh well there are there are
websites that have lots of incoming
links we probably care more about those
those kinds of things
um
and then but there's also the question
um uh this this this question of if you
have just a lot of kind of a Big Blob of
data how do you find what you want
well with search engines it's kind of
like when you type in the keywords and
you say this is what I want but a
slightly more more
abstracted version of what's important
on the web is a little bit more
challenging to Define I mean in the
early days of the web with things like
Yahoo and the and places where there
were explicit indices created explicit
sort of uh destinations listed on the
web there's a little bit more effort to
curate what's important on the web I
mean there's still languages uh in which
there's sufficiently little material of
that language on the web that it is
still possible to curate and we'll
probably continue to be so possible to
sort of curate what are the important
web pages and so on
but I think then it asks the question
okay so you've got an alarm for example
that's ingested the web and you start
asking it what was the important what's
important in the history of what we see
from the web
and my guess is that that will be
something that llms can reasonably
answer they may answer in a rather
uninspired way perhaps but they will be
able to answer these are the concepts
that seem to be repeated and seem to be
important and so on so that's my guess
is that there'll be sort of this vast
ocean of available data uh perhaps not
well sort of signposted at a very
visible level but nevertheless just as
it's easy to search it will potentially
be easy to pull out the the sort of the
trends of history that seem to be
important
um you know it's interesting because I
myself have a fairly substantial Archive
of material uh it's kind of the
consequence of having a decent human
memory is you get kind of spoiled and
you really want to really really
remember things so you want to have
everything sort of in an archive and I
now have about what is it 34 years I
think a pretty complete archive material
and then uh before that I've I've got
lots of documents
um and uh and lots of computer files and
so on but from 34 years ago it's fairly
complete going going forward to the
point of having you know every keystroke
typed and all that kind of thing
now an interesting question is what do
you do with all that stuff well I
routinely use it to search for things
but if one was going to expose sort of
what are the interesting Parts if there
are any of that term long Arc of History
how does one do that well I as a human
you know I sometimes write about kind of
personal history kinds of things and I
go back and look knowing that I am
looking for something about how I
investigated something about the
psychologics or some some such other
thing but if you just say what were the
big kind of Trends in my life you know
be an automated historian come on do
that so the first question the second
question is when it comes to exposing
all those documents what am I really
going to do about that because I have
about three million emails for example
and I have another half million scanned
documents things like this and it's
unclear
what one should expose what's worth
exposing
Etc I mean one thing that gets tricky is
that when one has that amount of
material it's there's lots of stuff
there that oh I don't know it's you know
the corporate secrets of company XYZ
from 30 years ago
maybe more and it's like is that still
secret is it not who knows probably not
but who's not to know for sure
um it's certainly and you know tracking
down sort of should we can we expose
these things is it non-trivial
particularly for company things because
companies may not exist anymore it may
not be obvious what you know what
happened to sort of uh uh
confidentiality agreements for companies
that don't exist anymore Etc et cetera
et cetera and then there are plenty of
things where there are oh I don't know
things people sent me and so on where
there's sort of a question of at what
point can you expose those things and
it's uh uh what point should you expose
those things do you expose those things
if you know do you have a make a
judgment call about you know will the
will be a better place if we expose
these things or do you just say well
just expose these things because the
value of action at history exceeds the
potential uh sort of is more important
than sort of uh the the making sure that
you make the world a nice replacement
for example some of the people we
mentioned like Ben mandelbrot for
example uh sent me some really terrible
letters and emails and things like this
which which um
when I came to write kind of an obituary
piece about him I at first really
couldn't write it because I I looked at
these things and it's like my gosh I
can't quote these things these are too
horrifying
um and uh uh you know later on I kind of
found ways to to do that but or at least
to do some of that but I think you know
in their raw form their
they don't make the world seem like a
nicer place
um and uh you know to give that as an
example and there are other cases of
things like that but quite a lot of
other cases of things like that
so it's a question of whether to whether
to expose those things I feel pretty
good about the things that I myself have
authored
um and I I feel like I could pretty much
expose all of those and feel you know
like I don't know maybe maybe because I
I've um I've been fortunate enough to
not uh uh or perhaps put enough effort
into to only saying the things that I
kind of want to say
um and uh that that um so that part is
probably exposable but without the other
side of some of those conversations it
becomes difficult to understand what's
going on so it's it's one of these sort
of efforts and Mysteries is is how to
expose that stuff and also how to
signpost what you should care about and
what you shouldn't care about because
all together in my own my own archive is
like three and a half million documents
and uh that's already that's certainly
enough that nobody's gonna just flip
through them all and see what let's see
what's there
let's see
um
that's an interesting question from
can we restore old lost books by reading
other old books which talk about them
interesting you know it makes one Wonder
uh
let's say
that
you had
uh you were you know scanning the web
and there's some
document some famous book let's say and
you find on the web not the actual text
of the book because maybe that's
copyrighted in some way and it's not not
accessible and or something but you find
all kinds of people quoting from that
book they find all these separate quotes
and each quote on its own is quite short
but you find lots of them question is
can you sort of reassemble those if you
are sort of sucking them from the whole
web and sort of trying to arrange them
can you reassemble them it's a little
bit like shotgun sequence shotgun
sequencing of DNA where you where you
break the DNA into you know like 30
blocks and then you figure out what the
overlaps are you try and reassemble them
my guess is you can reassemble texts
like that now the question is when you
have
sort of people who characterize or talk
about another text uh do they say enough
and can you look at it from enough
different angles that you can
reconstruct what must have been in there
it's an interesting it's interesting
idea I mean I know people have done that
kind of uh looking at I don't know you
know famous books like the Bible and
things like that they'll claim you know
oh they're these different parts of it
that must have all come from a common
source we can see that we can see
something about the common source by
looking at the the output in the actual
things that are there in the document
um but it's an interesting question
whether with LMS and so on well I think
it will be easier to do that kind of
thing how much information you'll need
to be able to sort of triangulate what
was that you know lot lost work of
Euclid or something what must have been
in it I'm a little bit pessimistic that
there may not be enough uh sort of that
was preserved that one can triangulate
back
and I think one of the things about
archeology it's always surprising is you
would think well we know a certain
amount about the past and the past is
the past and we're never going to know
more about it but the remarkable thing
is that as time goes forward and we get
more and more sensitive techniques in
terms of the physics and so on it
becomes possible to just discover more
and more about the past and also because
you know there are random things buried
under cities and occasionally somebody
will build some new thing in that City
and they'll excavate a place where
there's lots of significant stuff buried
I mean I've always thought that it's one
of the sort of interesting challenges
you know below a city like Athens or
Rome or something like that there are
probably many many layers of stuff from
classical times that it's buried there
but how was one going to get to it
because nowadays you know there's a
shopping mall built on that site or
whatever else and I I've always thought
it would be an interesting project to
try to make kind of a burrowing
autonomous worm type thing that would
just go and explore underneath some of
these history these cities with very
long histories and kind of it would go
there it would have to be I don't know
how it would be powered exactly but it
would just go and sort of dig its own
tunnel deep underground and kind of see
what it finds now of course one has to
be careful that in doing that as it digs
its tunnel doesn't dig its way through
that great work of literature that was
buried there I mean this is a famous
problem that uh this person schliemann
who excavated Troy was a famous problem
that that's why it turns out is a is you
know the historical city of Troy which
wasn't clear was a historical City it
was you know it was described by Homer
but it wasn't clear it was um something
and I guess it was mentioned by other
classical writers but it wasn't clear
that it was something that was real as
opposed to a mythological kind of thing
but uh has happened with many of those
ancient cities it was built in a series
of layers you know there'd be you know
Troy one and then something happened to
it I don't know an earthquake of fire
whatever else uh conquest and then there
was another thing built at the same site
that just sort of built up this the
sequence of archaeological layers I
don't think that was well understood
back in the 1800s when when Troy was
first excavated and I think then so the
the famous a very unfortunate thing that
happened was the person who was
Excavating it who gets a lot of points
for having thought to excavate it and so
on uh abused Dynamite to blow through uh
there must have been late 1800s I think
because that Dynamite hadn't been
invented until then to blow through some
layers to get to the really important
homerical error or whatever and
unfortunately probably that blew through
the homeric layer and blew it up the
dynamite which is kind of you know that
that's that becomes pretty hard to
reconstruct
um
but so that's the thing to avoid and the
tunneling uh you know the the
archaeological worm so to speak but I I
am very curious what there would be uh
in places where there just hasn't one
hasn't been able to excavate
um you know what would actually be there
and whether there are many things one
would discover from the past that that
are completely unknown today I mean one
of my favorite questions about that is
the anticothera device the one example
we have of a Kind Of A Clockwork
computer an Antiquity where there
weren't similar things produced that we
know of until the 1600s it's like there
can't have only been one of these things
this was you know there must have been
lots of them and I've always sort of
Wanted come on find the anticothera
workshop or the Antichrist Factory they
want to have been production line
factory type things but come on find the
workshop where you know whoever it was
maybe it was Archimedes was was
producing these things so to speak and
you know is that something that will one
day be excavatable and one will be able
to see oh yeah they made something which
was kind of like a uh you know a thing
that did these kinds of mathematical
astronomical computations and stuff
maybe we'd look at it and say gosh why
were they Computing that and that would
be an interesting moment
um
let's see
uh
Jimmy asks comments Seneca wrote many
many letters could be detective some
have been wrongly attributed to him you
know it's been a very common uh use of
kind of computer textual analysis or
whether it's you know Shakespeare versus
bacon and all these kinds of things you
know who really wrote this document
it is an interesting question whether in
this elderland time whether there will
be a more sensitive way to do that
because typically the way that's done
has been done in the past is just the
statistics of word use and so on in a
sense an llm is plugging into much
higher level much more sort of longer
range statistical properties and it's an
interesting question whether whether the
llm will effectively be able to detect
more easily those kinds of questions
about what was uh you know about
authorship
a good question I mean I suppose um you
know the the zero I thought a question
for an llm relevant to uh uh lots of
educational things these days is was
that piece of text written by an llam or
was it written by a human and that is
you know with today's llms there's still
a certain amount that one can do to test
for that I have to say I don't believe
that will be a continually thing that
will be continued to be possible you
think one can specifically train an llm
to evade any kind of detection technique
that one could come up with
um
let's see
uh-huh
the question from NATA about uh
historical approach
to exploring possible worlds and create
alternative historical hypothetical
situations and learn what when wrong
hypothetically
uh
yeah it's a an ask where the AIS can do
better at sort of telling alternative
histories it's an interesting question I
I I would think
that
that's a place where the sort of llmai
technique would be better rather than
worse I mean I've seen
what it does I've asked it many kinds of
things where it has to knit together
things which are sort of real with
things which are not real like I happen
to ask it um uh
I asked it um
uh there's a a language called Mixel
that Don knuth made up as a sort of a
generalized
um sort of uh pseudo Assembly Language
to use for sort of exposition purposes
for computer science and
um uh well I was was exchanging mail
with put on about about this about llms
which he initially was very negative
about I have to say I think I think he's
now a little bit more positive about
them but um uh so I just for fun I I I
asked
um Chachi BT to say you know write a
persuasive essay that argues that mixol
was produced in Paleolithic times
and um it it did an interesting job
talking about some uh I mean it it made
it interestingly it made a disclaimer
that I think it's been specifically
engineered to do
um that said oh this is just a work of
fiction because that's not really what
happened
um but then it went right ahead and made
all kinds of hypotheses about uh uh the
sort of emergence of rational thinking
and how that related to sort of the
emergence of programming Etc et cetera
et cetera I'm afraid it was all a bit
nonsense but it was still an interesting
kind of apparent alternative history so
I I kind of think that's probably one of
the one of the things that llms will be
able to do
um
yeah I mean I think um
uh math online's commenting isn't some
kind of um x-raying or ultrasound or
something safer than digging through
ancient architecture
um or is that still potentially
dangerous I I would yeah it's a good
question because you know we currently
think that ultrasound for example is
pretty harmless
again my MRI is pretty harmless you know
x-rays we know aren't completely
harmless I mean x-rays can destroy kind
of genetic material and so on ionizing
radiation from x-rays can destroy
biological molecules Etc you know
ultrasound maybe their issues if you
generate small bubbles and things like
that from the ultrasound maybe bad
things can happen so you know one of the
things about archeology is you have to
ask when are you going to excavate this
thing because it could be the case that
with today's technology you'll damage it
in some way if you wait 50 years or 100
years there may be a less invasive way
to do the same thing
problem is then you're waiting 100 years
and then you don't know what happened
for you know you don't know what was
there for 100 years and that's kind of
um uh that's kind of a bad thing
but um this whole question about some
uh
sort of Imaging of different kinds I
think one of the things is that uh you
know the Earth
soil whatever
um is is a bit opaque to lots of things
it's hard to image through it
um memes is mentioning here uh the use
of muons to probe pyramids in Egypt yeah
that's been a thing actually since ever
since cosmic rays were discovered
um people have been interested in using
them as sort of a natural source of of
uh of something that will penetrate
um large
uh will penetrate through through at
least to some extent through Rock and so
on and there was kind of an effort to
find you know burial Chambers inside
pyramids that were built so that the
various Chambers would not be found but
but now you know if you look at Cosmic
grade muons and they're coming at
different angles and you say well how
many muons were coming
um to this in this Direction versus that
direction oh with muons will be absorbed
if they're going through Stone but if
there was an empty space somewhere in
this pyramid
um then the new ones would be absorbed
less and you'll see some signature of
that from the angular distribution of
muons
um I think you know there was an attempt
at one time to use neutrinos which are
an even better way of getting through
lots of stuff to kind of do tomography
on the earth to look for I don't know
oil and things like this and that never
really panned out but it's certainly
something which in the future one could
imagine will be possible
um
so
let's see
uh
math is also commenting here maybe I can
help with more passive Imaging through
buildings I mean one of the things
that is a general feature of sort of the
current round of AI and machine learning
and so on is sort of putting things
together putting sort of shards of
information together in expected ways is
something that these systems are quite
good at so no doubt you'll be able to
get shards of a pot for example and say
well you know given that we kind of have
an idea that it might have been a part
given that pots were a common thing so
then we can assemble these shards to
make a pot now you know what will work
less well is the unexpected so to speak
some things where we know oh it's got to
be some smooth surface because it was
done with Pottery or whatever else
um it's going to be successful on that
but the thing where there's this totally
unexpected thing like the antacothera
device let's say where nobody had any
idea that any such thing would exist in
Antiquity I think one will do less well
with this sort of AI reconstruction but
the thing that is really notable is it
doesn't which we also kind of have
intuition about as humans it doesn't
take much
to sort of tip one off to what something
is you know it doesn't take much to know
oh I look there I see this very fuzzy
fuzzy image but I really know that's my
friend so and so
um
it's surprisingly easy to sort of given
the sort of Prior information of what's
actually out there in the world to say
oh given these little pieces these
little shards of information this is how
that must fill in just based on what I
know is out there in the world and an AI
is the current generation is doing
rather well of that that
um
uh wish comments a story I did not I do
regular know this story the library in
Pompeii where Scrolls were lost because
archaeologists tried to open them and
and didn't succeed
uh yeah I mean it's it's a it's a
challenging thing to know you know the
only safe thing to do probably is to do
nothing but even that may not be safe
because you know if there's some area
that is going to ask climate change or
something like this is going to become
different you know as the as uh
um is is there's going to be an Ice Age
there or something and then you know a
glacier is going to come through and
it's all going to be gone then
um you know it's uh then then you kind
of got to do something if you want to
preserve it
well let's see maybe one more
thing here
um
there's a comment here from Nick knowing
that weights will be a more efficient
means of archiving the centuries than
books and libraries
um
which will be an important thing because
the volume of polished material will
climb exponentially okay I think there
are several comments on this
first point is
if
that material that is growing maybe so
rapidly really has content
then it won't be compressible into a
neural net of a certain size I mean you
know Chaturbate has 175 billion weights
and is trained on maybe a trillion-ish
words of of text
so the number of Weights you know if you
factor in the fact that each weight is a
real number and that's more than one
character and so on of sort of raw bits
um it's it's being you know what it has
in it is something somewhat comparable
to the size of its training data
and I think
the question of can you take what is
being written and compress it down to
something much smaller
my guess is that that well sometimes you
will be able to do that because a lot of
what's being written is very repetitive
um but in the end there is in some sense
new knowledge that's eventually being
gleaned and that new knowledge is not
going to be able to be sort of
compressible down into something that's
sort of the size of just the old
knowledge now what I do think will
happen is that I think a lot of what's
in a chat gbt for example is knowing
things about how to string sentences
together and I think that can be done
quite generically without also knowing a
lot of we have to though some facts but
you don't need to know detailed facts
about everything to be able to do that
and so I think that there will
eventually be perhaps Not So eventually
there'll be sort of systems where once
separated off the linguistic fluency and
maybe even the common sense
from the attempt to capture sort of true
facts and knowledge in the system which
I don't think is something that is
terribly efficiently done actually with
neural Nets
so
I think it's it would not be right to
say that sort of we can just decide I
mean as people have imagined with with
sacred books of the past everything
that's worth knowing is in book X
everything that's worth knowing is
what's in chat gbt in 2023
um you know I don't think that's right
um I think that as human knowledge
expands that becomes less and less true
now uh
that well it does assume that all those
academic papers that are being written
all those websites are being written
aren't just you know rewriting the same
old stuff all over again and of course
there is a certain amount of that kind
of rewriting of the same old stuff but
there is also new knowledge and even
this whole idea of computational
irreducibility the whole idea that there
are computations that you have to just
do them in order to find out the results
you can't sort of shortcut them the
whole idea of computational
irreducibility is that yes there is in a
sense new knowledge that can be produced
that can only be got to by doing these
kinds of computations
so that's a um uh
[Music]
um
that's kind of a a different thing there
now Nick is is also commenting on on the
exponential increase of published
material
you know that's an interesting thing and
I wonder what's going to happen with the
the rise of llms because it used to be
the case that writing something a big
essay was a sign of serious human effort
you know just like putting something on
a stone tablet or something was a sign
of serious human effort well
that sort of serious human effort to
write an essay sort of got went away
recently it's perfectly possible then
the llm to write an essay without
spending the human effort
and so this idea that sort of you're
doing these things and they're vetted or
something by virtue of the fact that
somebody had to go to the right effort
of writing an essay that's not no longer
going to be a thing and so that means
that we'll be just vastly more things
produced where those things are
presented in the form of essays now that
may be a good thing because essays are a
convenient thing for humans to digest
but there'll be millions billions
probably of things like papers produced
which are automatically produced
and no doubt what reads them will also
be AIS
um you know looking for particular
features that the the owners of those
AIS want to find
but I kind of think that um uh yes that
there'll be there may very well be a a
vast increase it's it's an interesting
dynamic because there will be an
increase of volume and some of that
volume will be the result of irreducible
computations that were done perhaps even
initiated by AIS and so there becomes
this vast Corpus of material which is in
very human form but has never been read
by a human
and then what is the significance of
that and you know is there something
where the humans feel that oh we should
go and read through all these you know
10 000 years of uh equivalent of Journal
papers
just produced in the last month let's
say by an AI
um interesting question how that how
that ends up
um
Jimmy comments that uh prompting has
relevance in Psychology and philosophy
uh it's interesting I mean I I certainly
um
I mean for sure
when you ask somebody questions
the question of What kinds of answers
you're going to get depends a lot on how
you ask the question and what you've
primed the whole situation with uh by
it's interesting question maybe there's
actual I'm sure there is literature for
oh I don't know whether it's uh kind of
questioning people or or therapies or
whatever else there must be literature
it's interesting to look that up see
whether we can learn something for
prompting the AIS good good good thought
um
Authority comments could it be the best
prompters now are poets or better
computational poets
uh maybe I don't know it's the prompts
that we produced are are clean but not
terribly poetic
it is also interesting that this idea of
give it some examples which is a useful
thing in Exposition in general but this
is kind of showing you why that's useful
it's kind of getting thought patterns in
the right Groove so to speak to
understand what's being said
um
RBS is commenting I don't think Ram or
ROM type chips Will Survive the passage
of time or solid state drives well and I
think people also say that magnetic
tapes
uh will you know people have quoted
magnetic tapes as having a lifetime of
like 25 years things like that I have
older tapes than that which we have been
able to read
um and I don't know you know there's a
certain diffusion time for the magnetic
domains and I don't know uh what that's
estimated to be and I also don't know to
what extent it's affected by things like
temperature storage temperature and so
on
um but uh yeah I think that you know
some people believe that you know if you
etch it in micro size
onto a piece of quartz or something like
that that it's a better way to keep it
to have it survive of course you then
have to have the problem of uh you know
how do you read those things and that
becomes a pain
all right well I think that's as much as
we have time for today but um thanks for
all these questions I noticed there were
several others about more General topics
here which I would love to to address
another time
so well thanks for for joining us and uh
bye for now